让大人尝谁和我醉让醉
爱也罢恨也罢
聚散缘如水
手空倒的酒杯
轻重微醺的滋味
能走的情路太坎坷
谁和我醉一回
手空倒的酒杯
是否也装过眼泪
那些遗憾错过的人
那注定再也醉不醉
手空倒的酒杯
轻重微醺的滋味
好想找一个爱我的人
和我相依偎
手空倒的酒杯
看过多少是余悲
凡是山盟的承诺
最后全部化成灰
手空倒的酒杯
轻重微醺的滋味
能走的情路太坎坷
谁和我醉一回
手空倒的酒杯
是否也装过眼泪
那些遗憾错过的人
那注定再也醉不醉
手空倒的酒杯
轻重微醺的滋味
好想找一个爱我的人
和我相依偎
手空倒的酒杯
看过多少是余悲
来了来了
几乎是余悲
凡是山盟的承诺
最后全部化成灰
人呢
来喽
我熬过这所有的雾
到的地方开始风吹大雾
这几段艰难而返程的旅程
去尝回这辈子最难走的路
等我孤独的人
来喽来喽
要拿一包呗
哎哟
两个去了咯
高货群还有没有
有的
今天出来了好几条
那个高货群
卖了一个蓝色的
就这几条
还有这几条
还有三四条吧
看看
CP141
看一看看
这个灰色
灰色这一块
长款的这种
这几个都是长款
来这个腰围
腰围是62到66的腰
62 66
寻常在80的一个长度
这个29
原来都是59的这个
后面有隐形
拉链有个风机库
原来都是59
现在29块
这个你喜欢不
这个是一个灰色
然后还有一个是腰太小了
是吗
这个腰都不大
这几个腰都不大
这个有喜标
这个还有一个
这个这标记嘛
这个是
这个是一码一码一码
看这个
这个牌子
这个牌子来我量一下
这个多大的
这个也是62 66的腰
它俩一样大
这两个一样大
这个吹牛款
然后这个夏天的这个款
这个夏天穿
现在穿的
还有这个五发裙里的这个这个粉色
还有一条
那个蓝色刚刚那个谁抠走了
还有个粉色
这个蓝粉色这个腰围66到70了
还有个粉色这个蓝粉色这个腰围66到70了
还有个粉色这个腰围66到70了
然后这个红色我ION受烦了
然后这个裙长
裙长是83
裙长83
这个也是29
这个你喜欢吗
Q-U-1-1的
看没
看看
这个YOU是66的平铺
66M码的
这个能穿吗
这个牌子
这个是二码的
M的
这个是两码的
这个是三码的
M呢 这个是二码的 那个是一码的
66-78
66-78 这个可以穿是吧 29给你 ok 这个这个这个全就剩这一个了
这个全就这一个了
373 29
TB14183
来
来373
373 279 这种都是59元的 现在最划算
ok
ok 373 谢谢
来 还有一条这个裙 但这个腰好像也小 这个没有M嘛 这个应该也是个S的
这个牌子的 这个是这个牌 面料很垂 很舒服 这个现在也是现在穿的
侧边有拉链 这个腰好像也小哎 腰围66-70 这个66-70 这个能穿吗
臀围 臀围的话是106-116 全长全长是90 93
全长93 29扣3 这个能穿吗 66-70的腰
这个腰也不算大
但也不小
侧边有拉链分离扣
长度长 这个93的长度
29扣3 没了 就这几条
这几条高护裙
ok
来 这条裤
这个是一个咖色的一条
这条直筒裤
腰上
腰上的话是
破洞的
不对不对 那个裤 那个膝盖上是破洞的 腰上破洞的
来这个腰围68-72
68-72 臀围102-106
当长
当长38 当长38 裤长106
来这个39 扣6
39块 扣6 扣6这一块
39 扣个6
39块
扣6 扣6
39 扣个6
来这个
这个两边是有垫肩的这一块
然后这个全棉100高坡的一个衬衣
来ab面的
是
胸围
胸围的话是106 118
106 118
来这个长度
长度是56的
长度56
来这个1919
扣6扣6
1919扣个6
19扣6
来这一块
前围后围的一个灰色打底
可以当打底
也可以单穿前短后长的这一块
来胸围
胸围的话是126
126140的胸围
长度 Allegra
长度是60 608
这个9块扣个8
9块扣8
9块
9块刮8
够半 够半
9块
一口个吧
来 这一块
这个是一个大裙裤
这个是个大裙裤
这样子 一个灰色
灰色 灰色
后半边送你
腰围
64 92
裙长是86
裙长86
这个裤腿底下有个洞
裤腿最底下有个小洞
看没
好像没有洞
就是一丝一丝的
顶开来就有个小洞
看没 毛了
这个不介意的扣
来 19 扣3
大裙裤
19块 扣3
这么大一个
裤腿底下 这个位置
看没 刮 刮 刮
就是刮了一下子
跟那种感觉
19 19 扣3 扣3
其实这个不用管它
在最底下也看不见
你不撑开来都看不见是个洞
来这个19 扣3 扣3
39的一个新款
19 扣3
19 19 扣3 扣3
19 19 扣3
来 这一款
这个是一个灰色
灰色这一条
这一条是一个
那个弯刀裤了的
弯刀裤 弯刀裤这一条
灰色
腰 腰围小
腰围小这个
腰围60
60-74
平为96 110
单长36
裤长96
来这个39 扣6
是码小S的应该
39 扣6
这是个弯刀裤
39块
扣6 扣6
灰色 灰色的这一条
39块
扣6 扣6
扣个6 扣个6
扣个6
热不
咋又回老家咋呀
我几个弄那个
来这个
买几个
这个套到可以上那路边也
哈哈
这个还有那
那大背套我们看
那天那大背套嘛
还没下来了
我天晚上上那边去
那路边也不多嘛
黄城公园那里面
走到那边过 都是油套
油都不填
对
来这一块
这个是个均码
缩几3
W1机油的这个盘
袋子是可以随意调节的
袋子是可以调节的
后面有松链
来这个
腰围
腰围80到90
80 90
来这个裙长92
裙长92
这个9块钱能穿扣个2
97捐纸三
免97捐纸三这一条
背带权
带子的长短可以调节
前面是有一个直插兜
这个两边是有斜插口袋
来这个九块扣三
九块扣个三
有块
扣三
拿这一块
这个后面有扣眼
少扣子
米色米色的这一块
称一样
来胸围
胸围100能拉成106
100到106的胸围
长度463
这个九块
缺裤子后面
九块扣个三
九块九块扣三扣三
九块扣个三扣个三
来这一块
这个是一个蕾丝的
身上是一个蕾丝
背筋裙
第二个